hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everybody the left questions on my Game
of Thrones bonus video this week a lot
of people excited about a night of the
Seven Kingdoms and some of you've
actually read it before I think there's
a version that was also released
internationally early so some of you
have already seen it and bought it I was
a little surprised at how many people
had never heard of it before but george
RR martin actually has several short
stories and and other non Song of Ice
and Fire books that he's written before
in fact one of the questions I actually
picked out was about the ice dragon the
story that he wrote which is way before
he wrote Song of Ice and Fire so here we
go just careful for spoilers from the TV
show if you're not caught up with season
five yet you're the first question
grandma says I thought the release was
going to be graphic novels all brought
into one book is it just gonna be the
literary version of the story so you're
talking about the dunk and egg stores
yeah it's just going to be the collected
short stories it's not going to be the
comic book I haven't seen anything
recently but I wouldn't be surprised if
they do more game of thrones based comic
books so in the future next question
Anthony asks who do you think that
Elijah Wood could play in the game of
thrones universe well I actually you
know he'd have to play a bigger
character because he's a fairly notable
actor so it'd be weird to see him
playing some offhanded character I think
if they were to do a gone from the
book's gonna kind of cut him out of the
show he would totally be good for that
he looks like somebody who could be a
serious candidate for the Iron Throne
but since it seems like they're not
doing that book plot on the show that
you know just complete fantasy and a lot
of people might think that he'd be a
good Jon Snow too but he just he seems a
little too earnest a little too soft but
you guys can let me know Elijah Wood
Game of Thrones who's he playing next
question adam asks has george RR martin
finished writing the dunk and egg
stories and will the upcoming book be
the completed series or is he going to
be releasing more down the road well
right now the book that's being released
nine to the Seven Kingdoms is all three
stories that he's published he said that
he's probably gonna write more Duncan
egg in the future but he hasn't given a
timeline for that so you're better off
just buying this book the problem with
george RR martin is he has great ideas
but he has so many of them that there's
no way he's going to get to everything
right away right now the priority is to
get wins a winner done and then maybe as
he's finishing dream of spring he might
publish a more short stories as part of
Duncan egg or some other song of ice and
fire spin off so I'm not really
expecting any more Duncan egg for like
at least another three or four years
next question Karen s in the books Robb
Stark legitimizes John and makes
his heir do you think that would happen
on the show well I mean I think they
kind of teased that with the stand his
plot line this year that was I think
that was the idea behind that the
sentiment in the books is a little bit
different because John doesn't know
anything about what Rob was planning on
the show the choices put to him directly
by standard so it's like a completely
different emotional moment for him so
given his refusal of Stannis on the show
I'm not expecting to see that come up
again I think honestly I think that
stance is gonna be the one to take over
Winterfell eventually I know they've
been a lot of rumors lately about Jon
Snow having a battle with Ramsay Bolton
but even if that does happen and he ends
up defeating Ramsay I think he would
cede control of Winterfell to Sansa
because he would have to go back to the
wall to defend it anyway I think it'd be
really impractical for him to take over
the duties of ruling the north just
because he'd have so much political
stuff to deal with in addition to
defending the realm against the White
Walkers there'd be a whole bunch of
day-to-day stuff that he had to do so I
definitely think he would be very happy
to pass that on to Sansa next question
Hannah asks how do you think that HBO
would set the tone for Duncan egg game
storms are so compelling because it's
dark political drama with fantasy
adventures on the side but the
adventures of a night in a prince see
more light yeah I definitely think that
a Duncan egg TV series would be like a
straight-up adventure story the thing is
is the HBO would have to get people to
buy into Game of Thrones knowing that
there aren't any dragons there weren't
any dragons alive during the time of
dunk and egg so they'd have to find a
way around that there are plenty of big
action sequences that they have there's
lots of tournaments it's a much more
traditional fantasy story but you know
part of the reason why people like game
of throne so much is because it's
non-traditional they probably end up
using a lot of the same tricks to fix
those things that the main TV show does
right now like they drop certain
characters from the books they beefed up
smaller storylines in the books that
they're associated with characters that
they're focusing on let the show
wouldn't just be about Duncan egg and
then they probably play up some of the
drama between Aegon and his brothers
just because there's so many Targaryen
alive at that time but just in terms of
framework it would be less of a
political show more of just a
straight-up adventure narrative next
question Samantha asks can you do a
video on Tommen and Myrcella and what
you think their face will be on the show
well just to start with Marcella you
know my initial thought at the end of
season five is that she's dead you know
a lot people are like well we didn't see
your die we don't know if they're gonna
have antidote available most of what the
actress Marcella has said after the fact
makes it seem like she's deaf
dead Tommen is the big question mark
right now because a lot of people are
wondering about the valent car prophecy
the Maggy the Frog prophecy that she
heard it made it sound like all of her
children were gonna wind up dead in the
show it seems like it's slowly
confirming that but Tommen really isn't
in a position of danger right now it's
really Marjorie and Cersei that are in
trouble so I think the Tommen is
probably safe for the duration of season
six at least next question RG bats asks
wait was egg murdered so you're talking
about egg from Duncan egg so egg on the
fifth and almost his entire family died
in a fight like a mysterious fire at
summerhall and a lot of people think
that it was murder there's no
confirmation obviously George are Martin
hasn't said yes or no either way in the
world of Ice and Fire book it says that
the fire had something to do with a gonz
desire to bring dragons back into the
world but the other really interesting
tidbit is that Rhaegar Targaryen was
born at summerholt that same night the
really cool thing to speculate about
though is if this has anything to do
with some grand design like Rhaegar
Targaryen firm believer in prophecies
King Aegon try to being dragons back
into the world and everybody goes up in
flames on the same night that Rhaegar is
born in the same place so maybe Rhaegar
is a grand instrument of prophecy my
takeaway from all these mysterious
circumstances is just that Rhaegar
Targaryen is a very important person in
the war of ice and fire like the ongoing
war of ice and fire their characters
that are important during certain
periods in time like important to the
growth of Westeros and then above that
are characters that are important on a
cosmic level so i think that Rhaegar
Targaryen is just on that top tier
people next question add a delicious
asks what about george r martin short
story the ice dragon could you please
speak about that well so it's actually a
story that he wrote before song of ice
and fire back in nineteen eighty so it's
not technically considered canon but you
can loosely consider it associated with
stuff that happens in A Song of Ice and
Fire but don't take it as canon that ice
dragons do exist usually when people are
talking about ice dragons and Game of
Thrones they're talking about two
different things they're talking about
this short story from 1980 and then
they're talking about one of old man's
legends which are two completely
different things the old man legend is
probably closer to bringing ice dragons
into song of ice and fire cannon than
the short story is there's probably a
certain amount of truth to every single
story that old nan has told but remember
legends get passed down from person to
person they get
age to get interpreted in different ways
so like ice dragon could just be a
metaphor for Jon Snow being that he is
probably part Targaryen but for people
that want to believe that there's an ice
dragon trapped inside the wall you
you're not wrong like it hasn't been
completely disproven just because we
haven't seen it yet doesn't mean that it
does not exist so I'm not gonna throw
any water on any ice dragon theories or
anything like that I just I do think
that it's more of a metaphor than an
actual thing next question Vaughn be
asks I have an idea what if the White
Walkers are the first men not the whole
race just that the children and the
first men were at war then they got a
truce but if some of the first men
didn't agree with the truce and some
blood magic yada yada you so you're
saying yeah what if the White Walkers
were part of humanity and they got
twisted by magic I actually I do think
that that's pretty likely if White
Walkers look so much like humanity there
had to have been a common ancestor at
some point and a lot of the ones we're
seeing on the show right now are
Craster's children that were sacrificed
and then raised as White Walkers just
just like we saw during season four so
at some point in history first men were
probably twisted by magic and then they
began the tradition of taking babies and
twisting them and raising them as their
own but hopefully wins a winter the very
ominous sounding winds of winter will
shed some light on that like where did
they get started what are some specific
things about their culture that we
haven't learned yet next question Blake
coin asks do you think that they
actually killed Stan us in the show
since there are all these theories about
why he wouldn't have died and we didn't
actually see it happen so yes we did not
see it happen george r martin has said
that he's still alive in the books but
you have to remember like what's going
on where Stannis is in the books right
now completely different than what the
show is doing my take away from what
happened to Stannis during season 5
which is that he was not the guy he was
the guy that thought he was the guy and
it turned out that was not the case
that's that's why Melisandre bolted the
look on her face said it all like oh my
god I thought that he was this important
person this whole time and I was wrong
think about how many chances Stannis has
been given each time he just gets
completely shut down another way to look
at it too is the game of thrones like
that the whole story the Song of Ice and
Fire is about struggle and compromise
Stannis was not really great at
compromise look at jon snow during
episode 8 like had he been Stannis he
probably would have tried to stand his
ground and they would have all been
killed so I do think that Stannis is
dead on the TV show and I think they're
just opening up room for a new character
to be that guy
i but thank you so much for so many
questions everyone this is always a ton
of fun to do this is actually a big week
this is like the last week before a
bunch of TV comes back so keep your eyes
peeled heroes and Gotham are coming next
week doctor who starts on Saturday so
i'll be doing videos for all that stuff
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner robyn marie you in a twenty
dollar amazon gift card be sure to
message me on the back end my channel so
i get your contact info and a lot of you
guys have been requesting i do a bonus
video for some of the northern houses so
that's probably what i'm going to do for
my next sunday's bonus video a little
bit of grand northern conspiracy little
bit of background on some of the other
northern houses like the Karstarks and
the umbers so just in case you guys
missed it you can click here for my
Duncan egg video from yesterday it's
just a primer for this series we can
talk more about specific things whenever
they action release the book ant you can
click here to catch up with fear the
walking dead from last night thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you